I have no idea but chris pratt's
I hear I hear you are a magician dude
yes I am respect yeah
well I happen to have a magician like
like I know real magic yes no these are
not well I I know some tricks it's been
a while cuz these honestly these cards
Chris didn't bring these cards they just
we got them yeah you know give you these
cards I kind of hear can you do math
magic real mad magic yes not a trick you
have to be very careful just practicing
in the dark arts
lots of flourishes okay okay here we go
now it's been a while so I screw this up
just you know you'll cut it out um yeah
this is a whole new deck I haven't seen
this deck you haven't shown me this deck
you know that this is not a deck of
cards captivated yet okay so I'm gonna
shuffle it I also played a magician in
the movie The Magnificent Seven I saw
that it thank you
mom like movies and and so I learned I
got to practice a little bit there
okay I need um a volunteer should I
oh all right I got will.i.am is awesome
I'm doing a card trick for will.i.am I
love my life okay she is um okay so
here's what we're gonna do this is
called burnham and it works 50% of the
time so I'm gonna make three piles
now will.i.am may I call you will I am
yeah yeah okay yeah um take this card
and pick it up and put it on actually no
put it on either side of these piles you
want face up this card right here Oh
take you that car take that card and put
it face up on either side oh yeah
I get a truth yeah yeah and now take
that card and put it put it there face
up hell yeah
now this is your card but do not let me
see it but show everybody okay
that's your carpet don't see it okay ah
how much and don't say anything
oh good car and when you're in when
you're finished wait Ratman committing
it to memory put it back in the middle
pile anywhere anywhere inside the with
it anywhere you want in the middle pile
hide it and make it so that I could
never know where you okay you got it
yeah boom on that is action ABS on okay
now ooh two fours I call this trick two
fours i taked one four on the bottom one
four on top now what do I know I know
that your card you remember your card
don't tell me this is somewhere inside
this little deck but I don't know where
it is so I'm gonna put that in the
middle what and put that right there now
I want you to shuffle that four times
ah now I like I told you this only
works half the time so if it doesn't
work I'm gonna be really embarrassed
okay at 1 shuffle mm-hmm two shuffles
three shopping shash I'm in the middle
are you is good enough for me but that's
okay let's try now what all great
magician face yeah okay now I'm gonna
look cuz I'm gonna find your car don't
don't go look at my process a weight
limit movie how many chances you get to
find the car though cuz we can sit there
for hours I guess for oh you get four
chances yep
that seems fair thirty minutes each yeah
this is a dinner section Graham Norton
Show yeah okay let's see here no no
that's not it oh it's coming it's gonna
be here okay horn I think I got it nope
okay come on I get four chances wait a
second will you count four chances to
just shuffle through them or four
chances to show me you just know you
just look at me something for your car
looking for your card okay I got it
the first chance dear Lord God please no
market for chances yeah boom yeah okay
it's called Burnham I take one I burn it
I might have burned your card will.i.am
your card Helena oh okay hold on is this
your card
hell no just tell me your card now cuz
this could be it
what is your card you can tell me now
because I wouldn't be able to take it
out right oh it's an a an a of har a of
Hearts sure yeah the Ace of Hearts
[Applause]
I'm not a dime though your card 8a is in
this pile
I'll show Sam no no we lashes ham that's
good I think it was your card wait will
I am I'm not done
give me a fist bump wait a second magic
fist bump keep it right there don't move
it squeeze
[Applause]
graham norton here if you'd like to see
even more stuff like that then hit
subscribe or don't it's a free world but
I know what I do in that situation